[Music]
I'm in the locker room with my
Washington University in st. Louis
basketball teammates blasting the only
acceptable pumpup song for 2011 jason
Derulo's riding solo i'm a freshman
point guard trying to take it all in and
doing my best not to mess up the game
that we're getting ready for is the one
we've been waiting for our entire lives
a national championship game as we ran
out of the tunnel onto the court
anticipated the usual adrenaline rush
that accompanies the sound of a rising
crowd but the mild applause we received
was a total buzzkill
besides our families and a few loyal
superfans the stands were mostly empty
our national championship game turned
into something like a practice scrimmage
with referees I don't like showing
pictures from that game because the
empty stands in the background make me
feel self-conscious we lost that game
but I walked away with a deeper sadness
this is the reality for many women
athletes today they spend years and
dedication to their craft but there are
amazing abilities and accomplishments go
underappreciated what a serious missed
opportunity every person sports fan or
not can appreciate the beauty and
promise of women's sports
you should watch room in sports you
won't be disappointed let's take a step
back and think about how we got here
three damaging myths surrounding women's
sports
deserve to be redressed in debunked
women athletes aren't as talented as men
women's sports are boring and women's
sports don't matter let's start with the
first one women athletes aren't as
talented as men under this rationale if
Elena Delle Donne can't dunk like LeBron
James it's not worth watching
if Allyson Felix can't beat Justin
Gatlin
head-to-head 100-meter dash it's not
worth watching while it is true that men
have larger muscle mass that makes them
stronger and longer arms and legs that
make them faster it's also true that
there are other markers of athleticism
being a good athlete is about skill
finesse IQ determination and
sportsmanship all of which women hold in
just as large quantity as men let's take
a look at some of the most talented
women athletes I know you've probably
heard of Serena Williams Simone biles
and Megan Rapinoe but I'd like to
introduce you to three you might not
have heard of first Gwen Jorgensen
she's the 2016 Olympic gold medalist in
triathlon she was an accountant at Ernst
& Young and left her job to become a
full-time professional triathlete
she's now looking to become the first
American woman to win gold in the
marathon since 1984 Claressa Shields
two-time Olympic gold medalist in
women's boxing
Caressa has a really inspiring story she
grew up in Flint Michigan in a childhood
that was marked by poverty abuse in a
speech impediment and finally Cate
Courtney top American mountain biker she
went here to Stanford
Kate loves sharks in Shark Week in fact
on her bike where it says her name she's
changed the a and Kate to resemble a
shark fin because she says that's what
her riding cell is like she lurks
beneath the surface and then she pounces
right when the time is right stories
like these of talented women with fun
and inspiring backgrounds abound in
women's sports we just don't hear about
them only 4% of sports media coverage
goes to women's sports so it's not that
women athletes aren't talented it's that
we don't have enough exposure to be able
to assess talent accurately second
women's sports are boring altering that
on its head and ask
what even is boredom because if you're
bored watching some of these events it's
not a problem with the athletes I want
to talk about one of my favorites
women's sporting events from recent
history the 2018 Olympic final in
cross-country skiing the American skier
Jesse Diggins rounded the curve to come
down the homestretch she was a few
lengths behind and she put on one of the
most powerful performances I've ever
seen to cross the finish line and win
Olympic gold in this photographic finish
or how about NECA
Oguma K Stanford grad who hit this
game-winning shot as she fell to her
back to win the WNBA championship for
the Los Angeles Sparks so you're going
to tell me that watching NASCAR cars go
around in circles 200 times in a row is
more exciting than this
or that ESPN should put professional
cornhole on instead of professional
women's soccer the excitement around
swimming women's sports
is there it's up to us to pay attention
women's sports don't matter the World
Series and Super Bowl captivate men's
sports fans for weeks at a time because
women's sports doesn't have the
infrastructure or the media coverage it
can be difficult to know when the big
games and competitions are happening but
that doesn't mean that women's sports
don't matter
girls and women who play sports have
higher levels of self-confidence higher
motivation to achieve long term goals
and lower levels of obesity diabetes and
certain cancers playing sports can
translate into off field success as well
research from Ernst & Young and ESPN
shows that of senior level business
women in America 94 percent have a
background in sport and 52 percent of
them competed at the collegiate level so
if you care about the future of our
country and want to see a more equitable
world you'll know women's sports matter
professional women athletes are also
some of the most amazing advocates out
there you might have heard of the US
soccer teams fight for equal pay but did
you know that the u.s. hockey team went
through a similar battle in 2017 when
Colin Kaepernick knelt to protest
systemic racism in our country US soccer
star Megan Rapinoe was the first to
kneel in solidarity and arguably the
best basketball player in the world Maya
Moore has taken two years away from the
game to advocate for prison reform
specifically for a man she believes is
wrongly convicted and sits on death row
in Missouri once you know these women
and their stories it's hard not to care
the same way that we draft and follow
our fantasy football leagues or latch on
to contestants in The Bachelor that's
what I want for women's sports
which brings me to what you can do to
better support at Stanford it could be
watching one or two events live we have
some of the most amazing athletes in the
world right here on our campus in the
last year our women's soccer volleyball
swimming and diving rowing water polo
and tennis teams have all won national
championships that's six in the last
year when you're in a bar or restaurant
ask the server to turn this one of the
TVs to a women's sporting event even if
you're only casually watching the game
other patrons will stroll in and see
that it's on TV and it'll start to
become more normalized I can't
understate the importance of sports of
stories in women's sports invest in
learning about a player or a team and
follow them for a season maybe it's
someone who's from your hometown or home
State or someone who speaks out about a
cause you care about once you're
invested in their success I think you'll
find it's hard not to pay attention
another thing you can do is consider
being a coach for local youth girls team
being a constant presence in a young
girl's life can make a world of
difference
and finally as Business School students
I would be remiss not to plant the seed
that maybe one day you should buy a
women's sports team
and grow it into the most successful
sports franchise in the history of the
world I still have a recurring dream it
happens about once a month or so I'm
back in college this time as a senior
I'm in that locker room getting ready
for another national championship game
but this time when I run out onto the
court I met with a wall of applause that
sends me back on my heels I want this to
be more than a dream I want it to be the
reality for the next generation of
female athletes thank you
[Applause]
[Music]